The answer is 22,339 days. The way that we would figure this out, is that we
would open up Bluejay, and we would go into this days alive printer, and start
editing it. And the main method right here, we would first create a variable
birthday. Initialize to Sally Ride's Birthday, and another variable, Last Day,
initialized to Sally Ride's Last Day. Then we do the calculation and put that
in another variable. Here you can see that the daysAlive is an int. And then we
print out the result. Which is in daysAlive. I compiled, and I got no syntax
errors, so let's try running this thing. I go to the daysAlive printer, run the
main method, and I get my answer, 22,281. That doesn't match what I got before,
one second. Looks like there was a bug. This shouldn't be May 26th, it should
be July 23rd. Let's compile this again. Close it. Try running our main method
again. And this time we got the answer I expected, 22,339.